Hm
consciousness kind of overrides the
concept of time at the beginning and then
your consciousness just returns to where
it was and that the physical body and
brave is just a temporary instantiation
of consciousness in the physical bead.
But this goes back to some other
place and then there's like a figure,
we don't have the words to even
conceive of what that means.
And that is that the western language,
the way science is taught,
I can't really capture what he's
talking about it in that sense.
And so that's why I think we kind of hit
an epistemological wall there where you
have to actually get into introspection,
meditation,
and that the deeper parts
of that tradition that I've
never been able to really
get into personally.
So I can't say I understand it,
although I kind of see where
he's coming from in that regard.
So,
so let me ask you some
questions about that.
So the first might have to do with
this idea of the ontological primacy of
consciousness.
No.
One of the things I've learned
from studying mythology
is that the mythological
worldview,
first of all,
I think the mythological worldview
conceptualizes the world as a place to act
rather than as a place of things.
So it's sort of like Steven Jig,
Jay Gould's idea of two
magistarium don't overlap.
There's a moral magistarium
materialist magistarium say,
but it's been striking to me,
looking at the archetype will foundations
of mythological thinking that,
that in the scientific world view,
there seem to be two
fundamental causal elements.
You could say nature and nurture,
something like that,
or biology and society.
And then technically sophisticated
western academics argue about the relative
contribution of each to any given,
uh,
existential phenomenon.
But in the mythological worldview,
there's always three actors.
There is nature.
Um,
usually personified as female
or experienced is female,
cause personified isn't
quite the right word.
There's culture,
but there's also the individual and the
individual seems to be the same thing as
the conscious actor.
And that would be the hero of
the dragon slaying hero saves.
And there's that,
there is a kind of primacy given to that.
And so in the oldest creation myths,
you always see this
interplay between the mother,
often mother earth and the father that
the sky and then the hero who separates
the two and somehow bring,
and perversely in some sense,
although being their product clearly
as the offspring is also the thing that
gives rise to them at the same,
at the same time.
And it seems to be something that's in
keeping in some sense with our lived
experiences that we confront
the social world obviously,
and our beneficiaries and victims of it.
And we confront the natural
world in the same matter.
But we also seem to be a agentic actors
and without us as a gender doctors,
the idea that there's a reality seems to,
it seems to be full of paradoxical holes
like reality without a conscious actor.
And I think that's the sort of thing that,
that generates the thinking that you
referred to as characteristic of,
of Deepak Chopra and the people who,
who make those sorts of claims.
So,
I mean,
what's your,
what's your take on,
on consciousness and its role in being?
Well,
the one,
and it's everything because,
um,
it's what I tell what I tell deep,
like what I write about
in that chapter is that,
um,
you're,
you're familiar with
the anthropic principle.
So I call this the,
that the week consciousness
principle that,
um,
without consciousness,
nothing exists.
You know,
this is one of the points.
The book makes a,
and for me and you personally,
if we're dead or we're not conscious,
the world doesn't exist for our brains.
It's gone.
Nothing.
There's nothing.
Uh,
but,
but he goes further than that.
He says,
this is what I call the strong
consciousness principle.
That that consciousness is required.
Our consciousness is required
for material things to exist.
And,
and so there I have a discussion of what,
um,
uh,
Donald Hoffman,
the cognitive scientists
at Uc Irvine Colosseum is,
um,
uh,
interface perception theory.
Uh,
I don't know if you're familiar with this,
but his analogy is like,
you know,
your laptop screen here.
Then you'd have these icons on the screen.
They had like the little trashcan
icon looks like a Trashcan,
but of course there's no trash.
Get the Oakland,
the open your laptop,
there's no can in there.
You know,
these are just kind of icons that
represent something that we think of as a
trashcan.
And,
um,
you know,
this is,
gets to the problem of,
you know,
what it's like to be a bat.
Uh,
I can't know if like bolted on some,
some huge ears.
And I,
and I had an echo location system and
the neural processes to process that
information until,
and I would have some sense
of what it's like to be a vet,
but they had everything on
to actually be a bad thing.
And I would just be a bat
and I wouldn't even be,
I wouldn't even know I was a human
wondering what it's like to be a fat.
Okay.
So at some level we can't actually know,
um,
you know what it's like
to be something else.
And so you,
again,
with Deepak and I and these
kinds of traditions like that,
we hit this system
illogical wall of language.
It's difficult to say what
you mean by certain things.